.
>> ON THE RIGHT SIDE.
>> GIANNIS, OVER HERE.
YOU'RE NOW THE OWNER OF ONE OF
THE, YOU KNOW, SIGNATURE PLAYS
IN FINALS HISTORY WITH YOUR
BLOCK ON AYTON THERE.
I'M CURIOUS OVER THE LAST COUPLE
OF DAYS, HAVE YOU WATCHED THE
REPLAY?
HAVE YOU MOVED ON FROM IT
ENTIRELY?
>> FIRST TIME I KIND OF WATCHED
IT WAS TODAY IN THE FILM SESSION
THAT WE HAD.
BUT GREAT PLAY, YOU KNOW, IT'S
INCREDIBLE WHAT YOUR BODY IS
GOING TO DO, YOU KNOW, WHEN
YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT WINNING.
YOU GO TO EXTREME.
CANNOT EXPLAIN THE PLAY.
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY, YOU
KNOW, THAT'S IN THE PAST.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THE PAST,
THAT'S YOUR EGO TALKING.
IT'S IN THE PAST.
IT'S OVER WITH.
GOT TO MOVE ON.
I GOT TO KEEP MAKING, YOU KNOW,
WINNING PLAYS AND KEEP COMPETING
AND FINDING WAYS TO HELP MY TEAM
BE GREAT.